hey what's going on it's Bill bur it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast from
Monday uh January 15
2024 what's going on how are
you um I hope you're doing all right I
really do I'm not doing so good I know
what's going on with me I feel like I'm
[__] angrier than ever and I think
part of that has to do that I just I've
just I've quit smoking cigars so I'm
like on
edge um
I'm [__] on the road here I I I I
swear to
God if my my luggage was a person I
would just I just would have committed a
[__] felony against
it that [__] rim wash [__] every all
these fancy [__] things I bought this
thing I don't know how long I bought
this [__] thing I swear to
God the design flaws on the thing are
just I don't even know like you can't
you you put anything more than a
toothbrush and two pieces two [__]
articles of clothing in there and you
spend 10 minutes is trying to get the
[__] thing closed you know those
things that you know that lay down in
the clothes and you pull them tight they
they just as you go to close it they
just stick out they always get in the
[__] way and even when I get it
closed when I finally get the [__]
thing closed like I'll see part of a
shirt sticking out like I had a brand
new sweater it literally like it pinched
it like scissors and put a hole right
over my left titty and I had brand new
[__]
sweater and this the thing I have hated
that [__] luggage since [__] a
month of owning it and I bought it 10
years ago and I still have it and I'm
going to tell you right now that right
there in a nutshell
explains explains me and my [__]
childhood and all of that [__] this
isn't working for me you know am I going
to do anything to change it no I'm just
going to accept it and [__] tough it
out that that right there that right
there is the
70s and the 80s
I was sitting there going like well why
don't I I actually thought about that I
was like why don't I just buy a new
piece of [__] luggage and then I
immediately go with like but what am I
going to do with this one I'm just going
to throw it out and it just ends up in
the [__]
ocean you know that's where it all goes
even if I could somehow stick it in the
recycling like they're going to recycle
it they're going to melt down my [__]
carry-on bag you know so some [__]
you know hipster can get it uh um do
they buy recycled [__] I don't
know anyway um I just spent a uh it was
we had had a little uh getaway vacation
which was really fun with uh my family
here but I've just been like I was on
edge the whole [__] time I don't know
why I'm telling you cuz you know what it
was was I immediately thought like oh
you know we're going up into the
mountains oh I could sit on the back
porch and I could smoke a cigar and I
was like no you said you weren't going
to smoke a cigar until the Super Bowl
you said you were going to get this
habit under control so I didn't bring
them and I think like mentally I was
kind of climbing the walls at
night but we had such a [__] great
time up here it's the first time you
know kids live in LA it's the first time
they've played in snow so they were
loving it we had snowball fights we made
snowmen uh we went tubing stayed away
from the whole uh skiing and
snowboarding stuff you know I'm I I'm
not into that stuff Nia is not into that
stuff that just seems
like I mean you get into that hobby
that's it's like buying a vacation home
I mean I just look at them the sheer
amount of
equipment especially the skiers they
seem like they have extra stuff all the
[__] it's like golf on
snow you know all these golf guys with
the [__] the shoes the outfits the
[__] te's the balls the covers the
clubs the bags the carts the [__]
visors all of that [__] sh the cigar
holder it just
be it's like it's like you go into a
knick-knack store and go let me get all
of this well what if it rains I need an
umbrella that attaches to my [__] bag
it's just I just it's just too much [__]
and also
you know I got a tour coming up like I
was sitting there going like there's no
way I'm skiing like maybe if I get a
little time here I'll try snowboarding
cuz that always look fun to me but it's
like I can't break my ass you know and
then get on a [__] 6-h hour flight
you know back to Boston to start a tour
wherever the [__] I'm starting out and
it's just
like you know but I I you know people
like I will tell you this though back
when I did ski I wore jeans this is how
long ago it was jeans in a in a [__]
uh 80s ski coat and I would come down
and my coat would I'd be fine from the
waist up at the bottom i' just have snow
caked all over me I mean you know it was
a [__] expensive sport right so I I I
could I I afforded could afford the
jacket uh I will say there was nothing
better there was there's no better beer
I don't I my opinion than after a day of
skiing I never did the snowboarding but
I fig it's the same thing coming in out
of the cold yeah somehow worked up a
sweat in the cold and you come in and
you sit
down and you drink like you don't go to
get [__] up you just have one of those
hoppy [__] heavy beers oh my
God like I don't give a [__] like about
alcohol anymore like I don't think about
drinking but yesterday after we went we
went tubing I went with my daughter I
was so proud of her man she was like you
know it's a decent size Hill so we went
down together a couple times then she
said she wanted to go down by herself
and then on the last one she she had the
the person spinner and
um I was really proud of her and that's
that's that moment where as a parent you
really like fire your kid up and tell
them how proud proud of them you know
you are of them that they you know cuz I
could tell she was like nervous or
whatever since I remember you know first
time I went sledding you know I was I
was so nervous and da D you just make
him feel like it's all right to be
nervous um face the the little fear and
then you do it you see it's it's no big
deal but oh my God
was such a good time the one thing that
I didn't
realize uh the one thing that was really
like kind of wearing on me other than
not smoking cigars that was really
causing
me to be on edge which you know caused
me to almost throw my [__] luggage
out the window this morning
um was you needed you needed a
reservation for everything up
here we were like let's go tubing and
the first day it was like snowing like a
like a bastard is I they used to say
back where I'm from and um so we take
the bus up my son's all excited cuz he
love anything that's big trucks you know
he likes motorcycles buses planes
helicopters anything that just makes a
big [__] noise like he loved the
snowmobiles which I can't believe how
[__] quiet they are now and those
things see now that I could get into
like if I lived up here I wouldn't do
like the you know snowboard skiing thing
I but I definitely the uh the snowmobile
[__] that looks like fun as hell man um
so anyway we take the bus up and it was
awesome it was like two
[__] like classic California guys
right and um they're sitting in the back
of the bus like oh bro this dude right
oh they're like literally talking like
Spicoli so of course I turn around the
lovely Neil sitting behind me and she
has this big grin on her face cuz we
love like accents we like you know you
like going places in meeting like the
locals you know what I mean you don't
want to go there and uh it's why I
always hated about like cruise
ships and I only did one of those I did
a gig on that that did not go
well um and uh or I remember like a few
times I went on a uh a trip and we went
to a resort and you just stay there in a
resort it's just like I could just be at
like a [__] Hard Rock Cafe in
Columbus Ohio right now like what what
the [__] is the point of traveling if
I'm just going to hang out with a bunch
of other Americans in Hawaiian
shirts even though we're not in Hawaii
but it just makes sense to you you
know you know my people are we're
[__] funny hey we're near the equator
out out a Hawaiian shirt hey honey get
your hair braided
that shit's funny to me um I will say
what's funny is I saw you know on
Instagram you know this this white kid
was going like today I'm going to like I
clicked on one best sandwich in La now
that I'm just getting bombarded with
like you know these are the five best
barbecue sauces within your [__] area
con I can't I can't get out of it you
know it's like on Instagram you click on
one [__] and then it becomes like a
porn site it's just like can't just look
at one every once in a
while um I needed a new exercise for my
workout whatever [__] excuse you you
have right so um this kid's the best
burrito in [__] LA right so he goes
there right and uh it's one of these
things on the side of the
road guy's got like the truck and
everything and they throw
down
um and then like the amount of like you
know racist white people like do they
have a permit oh it's such a shame
they're taking away business from a
legitimate [__] it's like you don't
like them cuz they're not white that's
what it is [__] [__] they're
busting the r on the side of the [__]
road that's the American dream and then
you work your way up and one day you get
a restaurant you [__] [__] so anyway
so that's me trashing white people now I
have to trash Mexicans here because if I
see one more [__] comment saying that
white people think Taco Bell is Mexican
food you know it's like oh we are we
that dumb
really Taco Bell is not even food M Taco
Bell is no more food than McDonald's
it's like do you guys think [__]
McDonald's is European
Cuisine oh this is the real deal this is
Mexican food and I pull up to the
[__] uh the drive-thru and there's
some kid named Brad some white kid white
is I am giving me a [__] I I I tell
you I don't [__] it i' I've eaten
there twice tce I ate there twice in one
year I had never eaten
there because there was just something
about it it just the colors of it always
look gross to me there was something
about that
purple and uh the refried beans look
like diarrhea to me and I was just like
I'm not [__] eating there I'm just
not [__] I am not [__] with that
[__] and uh wasn't until I moved to New
York and I did a road gig and the comic
who was driving it was me and like two
other [__] one other comic and he
just stopped there I and he was I was
like I've never been here what do I get
and he said get the number seven burrito
or something and I got
that and you know in a fast food way it
was like all right and
then I was by myself on the road I was
like oh you know later on the year I'll
try it again and I hat it I was just
like this is not
[Music]
good and yeah so listen I don't know
what authentic Mexican food is as a
white person but I will tell you I I
know it's not Taco Bell all right I know
some of us are dumb we're not all
[__] dumb just like every every race
every race has their Mor Rons and has
their Geniuses okay you want to you want
to but for some reason races of people
all we do is just Define each other
that's what I it's like the Jerry
Springer Show The Jerry Springer Show
was the worst representation of every
race out
there I was just watching um I I saw
this I'm completely off the track here I
don't know what the [__] I'm talking
about here um I was watching this thing
on
uh I I watched a bunch of Instagram
trying to you know I'm a [__] cigar
fiend so I'm like trying not to [__]
smoke right um so at night I I'm like
[__] tossing and
turning and uh so I'm just like on
Instagram you know you're still looking
at your phone and your spouse is like
come on kid shut up scre it's too bright
right so you got you got to go down to
the lowest
setting you know what I mean and now
you're in your bed like some nerd like
smart kid that so can't stop reading a
book that he's under the covers with the
flashlight if that ever even happened I
think that was just in a uh in movies
right except you're a degenerate [__]
like me and I'm just looking at
Instagram videos and I saw one it was
the compilation best reactions to
somebody realizing they weren't the
father on um Mor
Povich and I used to I used to you know
didn't watch it religiously but I would
watch
it and uh and I would be rooting for the
[Music]
guys you know because I was single and I
didn't have any kids and
like I don't know I was just putting
myself into that situation I was like
there's clearly no love between these
two people
like I hope this guy isn't going to get
sucked into this for the next [__] 20
years of his life supporting the kid and
then like every family function he's
going to have to see you know have to
see each other again and I haven't
watched that [__] when the [__] did that
go off the air 20 years ago I had seen
it forever so I just you know it was
like scrolling it was the next thing
that came
up and uh my perspective on it
completely changed now that I'm a dad
they kept sh the pictures okay little
four-year-olds so and so and they were
all the cutest [__] kids
ever and just watching somebody being
excited that that kid was I like that
kid needs a hug that kid needs somebody
to help him out somebody to take him go
sledding or whatever and it ended up
being one of the saddest [__] shows I
ever saw in my
[Music]
life I think I'm going through menopause
I don't know what's going on with me but
anyway let's
[Music]
um let's uh let's talk um
oh dude this is how like on edge I am
too like they [__] when you went to
go on the uh the tubing thing the guy's
breaking it down right one of these
[__] guys that just shows the
outdoors and he [__] loves it you can
tell he's stoked and he's telling you so
he's got [__] great energy and
uh and I was just looking at the guy
going this the kind of guy I would have
partied with back in the day this guy's
[__] fun as hell and I know he's
funny as [__] and
uh and he would just he would have just
great stories or whatever so like I
immediately love the guy um so he was
sitting there you know talking about you
know how to how to get into the tube
when you get up top put the leash in the
things the label goes out front sit down
blah blah blah blah he said when you go
they this little [__] moving sidewalk
when you go up the thing was saying you
know when you get there grab it by the
handle have the the bottom side facing
you and sort of lean forward a little
bit right so everybody does it right and
he says don't don't like you know if you
drag it behind you then it's not
as it's not like you're taking up too
much space so of course the second time
we do it this [__] dump brod in front
of us has the [__] the thing behind
her right and she's on her stupid
[__] phone the whole
time you know and oh my God I'm judging
her right and all I want is when we get
to the top of the thing is for the guy
running the escalator to say hey lady
what do you think you're [__] special
what did we say right so I want that
moment of Justice which you guys you
know that it never comes right it never
[__] comes it happens in
movies right but it doesn't seem to
happen in real life so you see the guy
look he's yeah whatever they're not
paying me enough to [__]
reprimand this woman right and then like
she gets off the thing and then she's
like screaming to like her husband who's
ahead of her and he's he's basically
saying in a different language cut the
line and I was just like I [__] I I
don't like this
[Music]
family this family thinks rules don't
apply to them and then I was just
sitting there thinking going like dude
you're about to go tubing with your
daughter for the first time ever and you
you you're you're upset about this
[__] soccer mom who's not following
the rules will you get your goddamn head
in NE this is like my fight the whole
[__] weekend
um I'm blaming cigars but it's probably
uh I don't know once a year I take
mushrooms I think I need to do a little
check in here on myself but anyway so we
we
uh where did all where did all of that
start I just meandered away and further
away and further away and I thought I
was going to finish my [__] thought I
don't know what it was but anyway we had
a great time up here
um I will tell you everything now you
need a [__] reservation and then it's
just an information suck you know you
got to fill this out like I had to fill
out a [__] I'm not going to sue you
thing to go sledding and then they
wanted your name your age your address
email phone number of course I put in
all fake information but just watching
people doing you want to be like dude
you don't have to give them all of this
like why why would you do that um we
went to go bowling bowling there was no
[__] there was no do you have a
reservation he's like what is this
[__] Wolf Gang pucks it's [__]
bowling this is the biggest white trash
sport there ever was it's literally why
I'm
here yeah sorry we're all booked
up like I'm trying to get a
steak I'm going bowling a blone sandwich
and tater tops like right some watered
down beer that's [__] bowling do you
have a reservation it's like oh my God
but but what you know was cool was we
ended up going there was an ice rink
right down the street so we ended up
going skating which was uh which was fun
man
um and uh I'll tell you these [__]
people up here in the mountains they can
ski and snowboard their asses off they
can't skate worth a
[__]
uh I was just like oh my God I was I
just kept waiting you know that sound of
of somebody's head hitting the ice that
c that it's it's like a [__] it's a
higher pitch sound than you would think
it would be it's not coconut it's not
watermelon it's human head it's it's a
specific [__] sound it's nauseating I
still remember the first time I I I
heard
it I was outdoor recess and somebody
threw a we were
playing uh two completes of first with a
Nerf football I was in grade school
and this kid jumped up to catch the ball
which he
did but we were playing on the tar and
he just landed on his back and then his
head went C
really he had he had a pom pom hat on so
I think I don't think he was fully
concussed um anyway let's let's let's
talk about the uh playoff uh the
playoffs uh before before I even get
into it shout out to the
NFL which with one of the most overtly
hilarious
um gestures of greed I've ever seen in
my life and the way that they were
selling
it that you now had to pay to watch a
playoff game I mean playoff games on the
networks the amount of money that the
network gives you because of the amount
of
money that they're going to
[__] charge advertisers and that
that's how they got paid and the NFL is
like nah man there's got to be a way to
make more there has to be a way to make
more so they get in bed with
peacock what do you think the number is
huh 10 bucks nah too much too much five
nah eight that's a weird number seven
let's go
six I I know people would pay five but I
think I
think I think they would pay six
right so peacock pays him like $110
million to show the Chiefs versus the
[__] dolphins and then to charge NFL
fans like we're not paying enough for
tickets parking jerseys the NFL package
it's like it's one of the most loyal fan
bases in all of
sports all right and I'll tell you like
the level that they have marketed and
exploited like you want to talk about
like when I was just making fun of
skiing and snowboarding and golfing and
all this [__] you have to like the
amount of [__] you have to wear
evidently to go to a football game now
cuz I saw another highlight when I was
on Instagram of [__] Joe Montana's
drive against the Cowboys to Dwight
Clark the catch uh when they cut to the
[__]
crowd the way people were dressed you
could tell what they did for a living
like there was a there was some like
baseball hat 49er things some pom pom
hats that was about it no jerseys none
of this
[__] there was one guy dressed like a
pimp I mean it was [__] it was just
like you worked all week and then you
put your [__] you wore to work you just
went to the [__] game and now people
go out there like all the stuff that
they they they got on and the man caves
and all of this [__] you would
think that the NFL will be happy no so
they come they get we're getting get
$110
million for the TV rights to broadcast
this game plus we're going to get six
bucks from every single [__] [__]
that watches this
game right and this was my favorite part
ever was the way that they sold the game
they said become part of
History you know like we were watching
them land on the moon for the first time
like oh yeah I'll never forget where I
was when I ordered my first playoff game
on a streaming
service um that was one of the easiest
NOS of my life and uh there's a part of
me that hopes the entire league goes to
a streaming service and you have to pay
for it so I can finally walk away like
dairo and casino I can just finally walk
away from the incredible [__] waste
of
time that Sports his oh God then I'll
really be alone with my thoughts that
actually I should you know what I
shouldn't be attacking sports sports are
fantastic all right just the level of
greed
um and then this this was the best part
this was this was the [__] best part
some [__]
representative um Democratic
representative went at
um the NFL for their level of greed how
funny is that a politician you know now
I don't know if he was a senator a
representative but they're the ones that
voted that they can't be arrested for
insider trading and on average even
though they make low six figures a year
all of their portfolios are worth $20
million there's actually a guy in the
Instagram on Instagram I don't know how
he does this he says how he makes money
is he sees what those people are
investing
in um which is kind of brilliant it's
like one of those little fishes swimming
underneath like a shark and whatever's
left over you just come over and eat
it I don't want to hunt I'll let this
[__] guy kill everything and then
I'll catch the Nickels rolling off the
[__] table so anyway shout out to the
[__]
NFL um J when I I I think that there's
no [__] way for you to squeeze
another
[__] drop of juice out of the lemon
they figure it out um become part of
History like I I just want to be in one
of those meetings are they laughing when
they say
that become part of
History can they make eye contact with
each other when they pitch [__] like
that they have to be
laughing like how [__] I mean that
that the way that they sold it was more
insulting that they wanted me to pay $6
for the [__] thing
um anyway you know what they're working
to they're working towards
ultimately is the Super Bowl is going to
be a
pay-per-view and
uh I can't imagine like what that's
going to be like I feel like how
streaming services are working right you
know how ridiculously low their
prices cuz they're trying to get
everybody to come to them so that
they're the destination and I think once
they put everybody whoever wins
this this
fight I think once they
have closed down everything but their
streaming service and then that is
entertainment what's to stop
them from then raising the price and
being like all right we were giving it
away now it's [__] going to be a lot
more um it's really
uh I find the whole thing fascinating
because I don't understand I don't get
people with like at what point are you
making enough [__]
money like Roger Goodell makes like
like3 $40 million a
year and as much as people make fun of
that guy you have to work your ass off
on that job there's no way you can be
commissioner of the NFL and your phone
isn't blowing up 7 days a week 365 right
but you're also making $40 million a
[__] you it's got to be
great
right I mean if you're eating Taco Bell
every
night authentic Mexican food um if
you're eating that every [__] night
whatever you know what I mean if you're
living on a budget you make $40 million
a year you do that two [__] years in
a
row and then you live in the middle of
nowhere you never have to work again now
you don't want to live in the middle
that's one thing I have learned about
about up being up here in the m in the
mountains is um I am definitely a city
guy um I
just I I I would
rather get stabbed to death on on a
subway than get mauled by a bear and the
odds of both I feel are the same now the
people in the mountains and Out in the
Country it's not true [__] GE dick
work burer right and then people the say
like oh my God they're out there in the
mountains [__] their sister right
like it it's one of the saddest things
about actually traveling is you actually
start to learn that it's all like
people's ideas of each other are just
completely way off basis it's really
[__] stupid there's great people up
here there's great people the city there
generally speaking there great that's
why noise the shut out of me when Trump
goes I'm going to make America great
again it's like buddy it is
great it is great we don't need you to
make it great it's already is great it
has its problems like any other country
this country is great despite greedy
[__] like you right um and let me just
trash Biden now just so everybody feels
okay all right if that I mean even
though you know he's got dementia I
don't want to [__] trash a guy with
dementia but when he had his [__]
faculties he wasn't exactly a decent
human being all right let's go to the
playoffs here this podcast has putting
me in a great [__] mood by the way um
I needed I needed I don't
know [__] 55y old man fighting with
his
luggage um anyway okay first things
first the Texans versus the Cleveland
Browns not much of a matchup I was
really uh I was really uh rooting for
Joe flacko The Comeback thing but uh the
Texans just jumped all over him there no
reason to even [__] talk about that
game it was just an absolute as Paul ver
says it was an absolute
bloodbath now this game interest the the
hell out of me Green Bay Packers versus
the Dallas
Cowboys Green Bay jumps out to a 27 to
nothing lead and I feel like that's when
people stopped sort of watching the game
and really seeing what was
happening um the final score was
48-32 okay Green Bay had two pick sixes
they still only won by 16
points and Dak through for over 400
yards
um that that's not good stats like that
that it's not as impressive of a [__]
win as seeing them up 27 to nothing how
it ended up because in the second
half
um Green Bay's defense did you know
they L up 32 points no no wait no no I'm
sorry it was 2 then became 2710 they let
up 22
points but um I don't know I I just
don't that does not seem like a deep
playoff run uh Team to me however having
said that not the [__] [__] on Green
Bay's big [__] Victory how about
Jordan love and how about the Green Bay
Packers going what it seems like no
one's ever done this three great
quarterbacks in a row Brett Favre to
Aaron Rogers to Jordan
love bang
bang
bang all
right I'm I'm trying to think the last
time when I grew up they went Bob greasy
and then there was this four fivey year
period where was Don stro and David
Woodley and even they made it to a Super
Bowl under the great Don schula um and
then Dan
Marino I just remember as a Patriots fan
being like
[__] here we go again you know like I
saw this bear fan talking about that
like they're going to be kicking our ass
again um they just but I've never seen a
team do three in a row I mean that's
like New York Yankee [__] way back in
the day Ruth and garri to [__] uh who
was next was it
dagio Mickey
mantle 20s and 30s 40s and 50s 50s and
60s Bam Bam Bam they just had the
[__]
superar
[Music]
um incredible match if Luke Eric
lived you know this career wasn't cut
short they probably would had 30
titles um anyway so that was my only
concern about that I love Jordan love I
love you know watching Green Bay winning
and everything I'll tell you what is
stupid speaking of the Yankees it's just
like why do I need to listen to Jerry
Jones uh have like a [__] you know an
official statement that after a
disappointing loss he's disappointed
that's like some George steinbrener
[__] the Yankees have lost four games in
a row and later on this afternoon the
boss is going to issue a statement let
me guess George you're not happy with
losing [__] ego
Maniacs um anyway so congratulations to
the Texans Green Bay I don't know what
happened in the Chiefs and Dolphins
game um didn't didn't even see any
highlights of it uh seems like the
Chiefs handle them pretty
easily uh which brings us to which was
what we were saying on the uh the
anything better podcast about the
Dolphins they they had a great record
against Bad teams and not a good record
at all against good teams all right
Lions vers the
Rams um I was
convinced that that was going to come
down to coaching uh uh watching the game
and by halftime I was like the Rams have
figured out what the lions are doing and
they're going to come back and they're
going to win this game and uh they just
couldn't get it in the end zone and the
Lions made their plays when they needed
to make the plays uh I will say I was
the secondary on both teams is
uh I don't know I didn't really see
anybody this weekend where I was like
that team is going to the Super
Bowl um now granted I didn't see the
Chiefs and the Dolphins and also granted
I'm a standup comedian Ian so what the
[__] do I know um with that let me do a
little bit of reads
here hang on a second Simply Safe Simply
Safe simply [__]
safe wonder what kind of Simply Safe you
need up here in the [__] Mountains
for goddamn
Bears um anyway let's do Simply Safe
here uh Simply Safe you know now that
we've wrapped up 2023 and are ushering
into the next it's a perfect time to
reflect on what truly
matters uh what truly matters the people
we love most secondly behind that
knowing what year it is and updating
your copy uh this year resolves to keep
them safer than ever with the
award-winning Simply Safe security
system named best home security of 2023
by US News and World Report I trust
Simply Safe in my own home and recommend
it to everybody Simply Safe as
comprehensive protection for the whole
whole home sorry got the hiccups with
Advanced senses that not only detect
break-ins but fires floods and other
threats to your home and getting you the
help you
need uh with 24/7 live guard protection
monitoring agents can actually see speak
to and confront Intruders in your home
available from Simply Safe to act to
actually stop crime in real time can we
see videos of you yelling at criminals
in the middle of [__] sniffing
people's underwears uh 24/7 monitoring
is highly affordable costing less than a
dollar a day half the price of
traditional home security Simply Safe
prioritizes your privacy that's why
their indoor security cameras are the
only one on the market with physical
privacy shutters to ensure your privacy
24/7 satisfaction is guaranteed try
Simply Safe for 60-day risk-free if you
don't like it return your system for a
full refund Keep Your Home and Family
safer than ever in the new year as a
listener you can save 20% on your new
system with the fast prot Tech plan by
visiting simplysafe
docomomo safe like Simply Safe oh lastly
oh it isn't lastly no it is Lastly
lastly but not leastly policy
genius start the new year knowing you
found the right life insurance to
protect your family with policy genius
getting life insurance today means
you'll have peace of mind for the rest
of 2024 and Beyond so if something were
to happen to you your family can cover
expenses while getting back on their
feet luckily policy genius uh helps you
compare your options from top companies
and their team of license experts is on
hand to help you talk to talk you
through it even if you already have a
life insurance policy through work it
may not offer enough protection for your
family's needs and it may not follow you
if you leave your job with policy genius
you can find life insurance policies
that start at just to 292 per year for
$1 million of coverage uh some options
offer same Dave approval and avoid
unnecessary medical exams policy genius
has licensed award-winning agents you
can help which can help you find the
best fit for your needs no wonder they
have thousands of five-star reviews on
trust pilot save time and money and give
your family a financial safety net with
policy genius head to policygenius.com
Bill bur or click the link in the
description to get your free life
insurance quotes and see how much you
could save that's policygenius.com
Bill all right
Bill all right where are we here
um okay bob
sled from the Netherlands hi Bill for
Bob sledding you need athleticism oh
yeah I made fun of Bob sledding just so
I could get [__] Bob SLS to write in
however after my observations during my
participation in a Europe Cup and
America Cup in the world bob sled
Championship dude this guy's like a Prof
he goes sledding professionally I have
noticed that my definition of an athlete
is not fully lived by the majority of
Bob
sleders oh this oh he's giving us the
dirt the behind the scene of Bob
sledding this sounds like a will phell
movie Blades of Glory meets Bob sledding
the majority drinks too much and eats
unhealthy H the
Aqualung and because Bob sledding is
only allowed from an older age up to 20
wait and because Bob sledding is only
allowed from an older age up to 26
years is considered youth it is a
brilliant way to not have to face real
life after a failed Athletics or
American football
career and attaching a bob sled career
to it becomes a nice escape to avoid
dealing with
it all right this fil feels like a
second oh Netherlands second language so
I think what you're saying
is uh you're allow so after you fail at
those bigger sexier better paying
Sports a way to deal with it is to
become a Bob
sletter um did Hershel Walker try
bobsledding at one
point um and that guy's unbelievably
athletic after observing myself I
realized that perhaps what I initially
thought was influenced by my own
perspective I used to compete for the
Dutch bob sled team and surprisingly we
don't have a bob sled track anyway what
I know is that during the time I was
involved in Bob sledding there was a lot
of room for improvement in creating a
bob sled
athlete
um all right so you kind of agree with
me so basically whatever
country would loan their top athletes to
that sport they would absolutely
dominate is it really all
about that big push in the beginning I
mean after that you're just kind of
steering it down the hill right or is it
like microscopic leaning and knowing
when to lean and you all have to lean at
one time or that whole [__] thing's
going to go off the rails man um I will
say this as a kid I always loved it
Always Love Bob sledding cuz I was
sledding and I was just like look how
cool their sled is and how [__] fast
it
goes and uh when I was a kid you know
people died doing that [__] people got
beheaded
[__] I mean it was it was Big Boy
sled it was for all the marbles there
all right AI music question for
Bill hey Billy Bic oh too soon too soon
it is
over it's all done done the old
man um I know we're all paranoid about
Ai and the information we're feeding it
to make it
smarter um what am I doing what the [__]
what do you mean like like wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait how the
[__] I don't want Ai and I'm not working
on it how did you just make me a part of
this was this a [__] robot that wrote
this I know we're all paranoid about Ai
and the information we're feeding it to
make it even smarter
I'm not feeding it anything I'm jumping
through the Hoops these [__] [__]
that want to [__] robots and making me
jump
through um but have you ever stopped to
consider how much
AI is training us
already oh God I hate [__] people
like this this is why this is can I tell
you something this is why
people okay Joe sixpack is always going
to get
[__] because there's always going to
be the Counterpoint there's always the
narcissist there's always the [__]
person that just wants to get attention
this this just a [__]
contrarian that's just going to cause an
argument rather than than us all getting
on the same [__]
page all right the fact that the
information is out
there that these senators and
representatives are [__] insider
trading with these pieces of [__] that
are [__] us over and they're
allegedly in there to represent us
conservatively or in a liberal way and
they're just not doing it they're just
lining their own pockets and the fact
that that doesn't get any [__]
traction and we as regular people cannot
get on the same page to just [__] about
that just start with that can't [__]
do it [__] politicize everything it
just it just it's this is going to be so
depressing to read anyway I was
listening to Spotify today and got the
urge to listen to the song don't mean
nothing by Richard Marx I
know because I like the slide licks by
Joe Walsh on that track but then I
realized hey I can't do that if I play
that song the algorithm is going to
think I like Richard Marx and then it's
going to
start turning up in every one of my
recommended playlist all right I still
pay for music if I like a song I I buy
it um but it used to be 99 cents
per now Apple just switched to like you
give us 20 bucks a month and you get all
the
music like they all do they just totally
devalued the artist yeah you ain't worth
[__] if everybody gives me 20 bucks you
can get all of their work for free and I
won't pay them [__] um I'd be literally
telling the AI I'm a chick who had his
posters on my wall in the 80s no well
then you just after that just download
like [__] Brew or something then
they'll be like we don't know what the
[__] to do with this person anyway what
I'm going to do okay wait I'd be
literally telling the AI I'm a a chick
who had his posters on my wall in the
80s when I'm a dude who banged his head
to maiden and the
Scorpions all right I read you wrong
maybe I'm the [__] problem in the
discourse Jesus that's not a stretch at
all um if that that isn't bad if if that
isn't bad enough I'll do something
similar if a song comes on from a band I
really like but I'm kind of burnt on now
like Van Halen ACDC or
Metallica uh I'll be like I don't want
to hear that this song right now cuz
I've heard it a million times but then
I'll think wait if I signal the AI I
don't like Van Halen that's basically
killing who I am or at the very least
it's killing the younger version of
myself I'm a guy that [__] loves Van
Halen ACDC Metallica you know what the
[__] problem is is they play the same
four [__]
songs back and black is such an
incredible album All they play is You
Shook Me All Night
Long like ACDC in three songs for the
radio is You Shook Me All Night Long
thunder
struck and then I would I don't even
know if a Bon Scott song even makes it
Highway to Hell Maybe
those are the only out of all those
[__] albums and all of those [__]
great songs that's all they
play u Metallica and nothing else
matters and then they'll play [__]
[Music]
uh s Enter
Sandman and every once in a while when
they want to get crazy they'll play like
Master of Puppets and they just
completely
ignore um and justice for all that whole
[__] album
um anyway the person says how [__] up
is that I'm literally trying to outsmart
an algorithm so it doesn't screw up my
music's uh Cur curation what kind of
orwellian [__] is that no I I I did
that with
Netflix I always tell this story I
watched I watched one season of narcos
and then everything on my [__] queue
was
was was you know behind the scenes
Riker's Island um thep five drug dealers
of [__] August and I just was
like that's how I ended up finding one
punch man I watched like Japanese anime
because I was trying to just totally
throw this thing
off um Anyway by the way now that you've
finally done shrooms about time [__]
it's an 80s guy what are you [__]
queer uh do black light posters finally
make sense to you that's
funny um I'll be honest with you I'm I'm
glad that I did mushrooms later in
life rather than when I was young cuz it
would just be like I did that then I was
seeing this and [__] wow man as
opposed to actually getting something
out of it oh not saying the other way
wouldn't have been fun too I don't know
what I'm talking
about um all right here we go the
Persian
chessboard uh Hey Boba Fett bill I
recently read something kind of insane
in a Carl San book and thought I'd
share a Vier
for an ancient I don't even know what
that is for an ancient Persian king
invented chess hang on a
second here we
go they invented chess white people like
the original like streaming
service we just took all of this art for
ourselves a vizier Wier is a high-
ranking political adviser or minister in
the near East oh a kiss ass okay we got
those over here all right the King was
so blown away by the game that he says
to the visier you can have anything you
want as a reward a palace or two
Treasures dancing girls you name
it you name it uh the Vier comes back to
the king and says all I want is one
single grain of wheat for the first
Square then two grains for the second
Square then double it for each Square
after oh God this is a math problem the
king laughs at the request and tells the
head of his Grainery to Grant the
vizier's request and what he starred
everybody so the visier gets one grain
in the first Square then two in the
second four in the third eight and the
fourth and so on here's the thing though
by the time he gets to the 64th Square
the visier is own 18 quillion 446
quadrillion
744 trillion 73 3 b79
m551 615 bits of
grain yeah but the king be like yeah
[__] you you nerd behead this [__] um
I found the above impossible to believe
so I calculated it on the calc and
indeed that is that is correct thanks
for the laps and looking forward to your
2024 output go check yourself mate go
Checkmate yourself sorry I [__] it up
um I really think I have a little bit of
Dyslexia I move [__] around
um
wait so is this
just is that that's just a story cuz no
king would would actually pay that
that's probably why he's
laughing like he's like I don't know
what this nerd's up to but if if I don't
like it we're just going to kill him um
longdistance
love sounds like a Phil Collins song
when he's making pop mus
music long distance love oh you just
have to wait um that was actually a
cover um longdistance
love long distance
lover was that a Marvin Gay
song that sounds like a funk song
ripping off a hit song all right hello
Bill the hello Billy the ball bag I'm
looking for advice it's time for advice
with your sply bird I'm ripping off this
Melody from somebody else I'm looking
for advice from someone a little older
and wiser but they didn't respond so I
thought I'd try my favorite
comedian oh God that was that was a nice
eloquent slap to the face and I'll take
it I'm 25 living in the UK and my
girlfriend is 26 living in the
Philippines she's gorgeous she's
Filipino I mean it just I don't know
that there's not a good look looking
Filipino um she's gorgeous sweet caring
and everything I want in a relationship
we have been in a relationship for a
little over 3 years after meeting online
one drunken
night uh we meet up two to three times
each year meeting each other's family
and traveling around the world together
the only problem is the distance between
us I want to close that 7,000 M
difference and have her live with me in
the UK we have spoken at
and it's what we both want okay the only
problem is to get her to stay here I
have to marry her I'm not religious but
marriage is sacred to
me but uh only do it once kind of guy
you guys are killing me this week with
the [__] words you're leaving out the
only problem is get okay I'm not relig
I'm not religious but marriage is sacred
to me only do it once kind of guy all
right when we meet it when we meet it's
like a
honeymoon so that dose of what reality
is like together doesn't exist which
makes me nervous the longest we have
lived together is 3 months and it's not
enough to know how combatible we are
under the same Ruth I do think that she
could be the girl I'm meant to be with
but it's a huge risk what would you do
in my situation thanks and go [__]
yourself well I think the fact that
you're even thinking this [__] that's
probably not a good sign you lived with
her for 3
months I don't know I think I think you
know in 3
months people back in the day they used
to get married super quick and then you
know the guy have a white beater on and
be beaten around on the fire escape I
mean look how that works I don't know I
I
I um I hope it works out for
you um there's I mean there's a lot of
variables in that whole [__]
thing
[Music]
um I don't want to add to the
variables
all right I will you ask me okay what's
some gorgeous Filipino chick [__]
dating some [__] you know pasty
English guy from around [__] 7,000
goddamn miles away do you got money if
you don't have money then I'm buying
this but I'm a little nervous that you
know she's trying to get the [__] out of
there any way she can and she needs
citizenship so she's willing to marry
her there's also that if you want to
throw that in there there's a lot of
[__] [__] going on but I I as an
outsider you know I don't know what you
feel when you see
her
so I don't know I don't know what to
tell you I know this is what I can tell
you I'm glad I'm not in that situation
um but you seem like you you had more
questions than answers I mean you see
what if this what about that I mean I
know I [__] love her but you know
what if that's just the honeymoon thing
what if it's [__] this and d d I mean
you know I hate this thing but you know
when they say you know when you know it
is true you do know when you know it it
it's easy silence is comfortable you
Just Vibe it makes sense and pretty
early on you're like holy [__] I'm going
to spend my life with this person all
right if you're not feeling that then
you know I don't know what to tell you
however you you do seem like you're
living between your your ears a little
bit here
so
um why don't you pitch this with her why
doesn't she get an extended stay and say
like look all right well why don't we
[__] stay together for a h Jesus
Christ then you got to go through that
thing I'm so happy I'm married such a
[__] pain in the ass dating um
there's another reason too like you
never would have met this chick if it
wasn't for the [__] internet and now
look at the situation you're in trying
to close a
7,000 mile
Gap I mean it was bad L it was bad
enough when Tom Hanks was sleep
Sleepless in
Seattle right I've never seen that
movie I've never I would pay for an NFL
playoff game before I would watch that
[__]
movie
um I love Tom Hanks I hated the premise
of that movie I hated the name of that
[__] movie I hated the people that
like that
movie
um it was just literally like you know
everybody makes fun of those Live LA
laugh love signs that like everybody had
in their house and now everybody's
acting like they don't they didn't you
know um that if if you were going to
make a movie the movie version of
that
um
uh some guy emoting on the [__] radio
oh my
God Jesus Christ how could the same same
industry that gave you Charles Bronson
movies give you that I mean it's just
[__] it's it's it's
amazing
uh
um Houston we have a problem Tom Hanks
is Sleepless in
Seattle haven't said that I I uh all
right let's do it right
now your your top three Tom Hanks movies
I'm coming right out of the gate
honorable mention buzz and buddies I
love that [__] show
splash I love that [__] movie you
know why I liked his [__] car he had
that [__] sick ass
BMW and then he's banging a mermaid I
mean John candi's in it I'm in I'm in um
I like the movie he did with Jackie
gleon he had that [__] sick ass Jeep
CJ that he was driving around in and
it's got Jackie Gleason in it I'm
[__]
in
[Music]
um oh this next one's tough I mean now
you got all the big
ones
um you got Philadelphia you got uh
Houston we got a problem you got Saving
Private
Ryan
[Music]
um I think I go saveing Private
Ryan I also like The Money Pit I also
like the BBS like I like those [__]
comedies that he did back in the 80s I
like those too Tom Hanks is one of those
guys like before you realize it like you
saw like all like the last 20 of his
movies you've seen like 18 of them Tom
Cruz is like that I remember I thought
like I you know I was sort of like yeah
I like Tom Cruz but he wasn't
like the main person that I liked and
then one day they listed his movies it's
like I've [__] seen all of
those I've seen all of those in the
movie theater I saw all of those [__]
movies
[Music]
um um underrated Tom Cruz
movies uh losing
it um oh my God I can't remember was the
football one he made right right before
risky business I think it came out after
it that was a good one The
Outsiders all my shit's going to be from
the
80s uh Top Gun and I watch that as the
drama it was meant to
be
um oh
[__]
Rainman born in the 4th of July I never
saw
cocktail that one I I that one I was
just like they're just they're just
banking on Tom Cruz here I'm not
watching him flipping around a bunch of
[__] stupid bottles behind a bar you
know he he's
[Music]
he's he's up there making
Manhattans how how am I going to get 90
minutes of entertainment out of a guy
that was probably Tom Cruz's
Roadhouse you
[Music]
know
um that's actually a fun thing because I
I love movies and movie stars and all of
that [__] that's how I ended up in this
[__] business it really was movies um
naming like the top ones and you got to
go okay here's the thing you write in
top three and you can't go ACDC You
Shook Me All Night Long [__]
Metallica Enter Sandman I want deep
Cuts all right Jack Nicholson The Last
Detail that's what I'm looking for I
don't want to
[__] you
know although he's got some that even
though they were like One Flew Over the
CER nuts it's just
[__]
that's just that that [__]
scene um when he he's he's pretending to
watch the baseball game oh my God and
then everybody who's in it it was just
that that was incredible actually the
the woman who who played Nurse ratchet
who was absolutely gorgeous and
everybody just remembered her for
playing that role I remember seeing her
in a uh an old like I think an episode
of The Untouchables and I was like oh my
God who is that she's like a a
knockout and I looked up I was like holy
[__] that's the person who played Nurse
ratchet she was so in that
role
um that you didn't even see like how
beautiful she was oh Jesus Bill you're
going to get poetic on this here oh God
all right that's that's the
podcast um go [__] yourselves and I'll
talk to you
later